good afternoon everybody it's been a
long day so I'm sure everybody's brains
are a little bit tired so the upside is
this is going to be sort of meta we're
not going to be looking at a lot of code
but we're gonna be thinking about
reading code and techniques for doing
that so my talk is called reading other
people's code my name is Patricia oz I
am a programmer generally you would call
me a C++ programmer that's what I've
been doing mostly for the last 13 years
I've been programming for about 18 years
so my second language would be probably
Java JavaScript Python my last job which
I I left in July was at Vivaldi are
working on the Vivaldi browser I just
recently started up for myself as a
consultant in my own company called
turtle psych so that's it thanks before
Vivaldi I worked for Cisco for five
years working on telepresence systems I
was a Java consultant for couple years
and before that I worked on the original
opera browser I have a master's in
computer science okay
so this is this is the plan for today so
the first section is so you got somebody
else's code and we're gonna talk a
little bit about that and then some
things that you should try to get done
before you actually dive into the code
then ten techniques for handling the
code and then we're gonna talk a little
bit about excellence at the end so you
got somebody else's code and probably
felt a little bit like that
because somebody else's code is just not
like your own code is it so the first
thing that when it's a is that learning
and reading somebody else's code is not
a code review I'm not going to talk
about code reviews pretty much what I'm
going to talk about is trying to learn
somebody else's code maybe because you
want to add a feature fix a bug just
because you're curious you have this
fancy framework you want to learn
open-source project you want to deep
deep dive in and so how do you do that
when it is completely unknown to you and
I'm saying this is not a code review
because that isn't a very important
thing to remember and it's probably the
most important thing you can remember
because if you approach other people's
code wanting to learn then you will
learn if you approach somebody else's
code with the aim to criticize then you
will only achieve being able to
criticize it's very very difficult to
learn if you are in a critique
critiquing mindset so it's the most
important thing if you really want to
learn somebody else's code is to step
back this is not a code review this is a
learning exercise and somebody said that
a little bit better than me Dale
Carnegie wrote a really famous book
called how to win friends and influence
people it's actually a pretty good book
it's really old and instead of
condemning people let's try to
understand them let's try to figure out
why they do what they do and that's a
lot more profitable and intriguing than
criticism it breeds sympathy tolerance
and kindness and the reason why I say
this it's because if you are digging
into some kind of open source project
it's probably because you want to
contribute to this project somehow these
people are generally strangers to you
these people in this project and you
want them to like you starting off by
writing your first pull request
refactoring their code is not a good way
to make people like you
so again we're in a learning mindset so
this is how I think about programming I
have I construct a mental machine in my
head and it has certain functions
information flows through it you can
influence it in different ways but when
I program I have to serialize this
machine into code and the code looks
vastly different from this machine that
I have inside of my hand and one of the
things that you will see very often is
that when you approach somebody else's
code you don't have that mental machine
you don't have the mental model of the
code all you have is the code and you
could have hundreds maybe thousands of
files when you run code running code is
not linear you jump from place to place
you jump from one function in one class
to another function in another class
through layers of abstraction when you
execute code it doesn't execute line by
line in one file any kind of significant
size program will be jumping around the
lock when it's executing so when you
want to read code you can't do it
linearly either of course you can do
that for very small projects if you have
a project that's only a couple of files
or a few hundred lines I'm sure you can
read it from start to finish but that
doesn't scale I've worked on some really
big code bases my first code base that
I've worked on professionally was a
browser and browser is huge and if you
think about it you realize it's huge we
you have the own network stack you
having of your own crypto libraries you
have your own rendering library
generally have your own gooey libraries
you have you have your own composition
engines you have compilers jitters all
sorts of things browsers are huge and we
thought they were a birth last Diwali is
a chromium based browser so the vault is
called plus chromium code is 600
thousand files so you can't just start
in the beginning and read it until the
end or or you know you can't just print
it on sheets of paper and sit down in
the chair so this doesn't scale so you
need some some other way of digging into
this so before you start I have some
tips these are not the techniques but
their tips gives the help so I said
before you start but actually myself I
would say getting started because very
often you will feel very intimidated you
have all of this stuff you don't know it
you don't and then it seems complicated
and you don't know where to start and
it's really hard to get started so get
started you can do simple things that
you know how to do which you will need
so the first thing is get the code get
the code locally get it on your machine
some people try to do this like have it
on the internet and you can Google
search or something around it it's very
very difficult and very many a lot of
tools are not available to you so
download the code and have the booklet
on your machine if it's not in source
control get in into source control it's
very easy it would get to make a local
repository so just get in a dot add
everything so you have it in source
control and the reason for that is that
you generally want to reset hard often
because you've added all sorts of stuff
all over the place they may might might
even have broken something and you just
want to go back and try to put it in as
of a smart ID as you can because you're
going to try to use the functionality of
a ID as much as you can to jump around
or understand things and build it run it
and preferably in a debugger because I
will give you the opportunities of
setting breakpoints expecting the stack
inspecting runtime state and try to run
the tests and I would do them in this
order as much as possible of all of
these things and like I said I said
before you start but also a way to get
started all of these things are things
that you feel you can do you can read
the documentation internal assess how to
build it it says how to check it out
it's things steps that you can
comfortably do without like freaking out
but you don't need them to so motivation
generally you're out to learn something
first some reason either because you're
curious or because you needed to
accomplish some kind of task but I'll
put that I've learned something but
sometimes that task isn't really
productive and it's hard to get
motivated around it so then I say okay
so make proxy goals you can make a proxy
goal like I want to make some
documentation for this project making
documentation is something that if you
do if your pull request is instead of a
refactor your first pull request is
documentation they will love you
it's a very good way to make people in
open source projects love you so it's a
good way so if you want to say okay I'm
going to learn this thing I'm going to
write it out I'm going to understand it
and afterwards I'm gonna polish all of
my notes and I'm going to give them to
this project as documentation then
you've accomplished two things you
learned something and you kind of
started on in a good way with these
people also if it's an in-house project
then or it's something that many people
of your colleagues are also using then
you can do it too you can use what
you've learned to teach others so
basically you can set a hard deadline
for yourself you go Mike you go to about
something I'm going to have a
presentation about this framework in two
months okay you know and as long as it's
something that everybody uses then that
will generally be popular so like I said
when you have files files don't look
like executing code files are very
linear you they're written from top to
bottom but when you run a code you kind
of jump around and what we want to do is
try to understand how this thing
actually works because we have all of
the code but we don't have the mental
model so we have to have some way of
constructing at least parts of this
machine at least the parts that you find
interesting or the central pieces
so code is like balls of yarn on the
floor it's a mess right it's it's like
how do you start we find an end and you
pull on it so that is like the first
part and that's generally how you get
started the process is very organic so
basically you kind of you kind of look
around you're trying to learn stuff you
write notes you draw drawings you try to
like learn something and then you move
on to a different technique and then you
enrich these things in an iterative
process so I encourage you to take lots
of notes and draw and then go back to it
and go but like as you learn more okay
so I call the ten techniques or finding
an interesting and to put one so these
are the ten techniques I'll read them up
and then we'll go through them so the
first one is prepping where is this
button following input events what do
the tests do refactoring reading main
the graphical layout runtime
investigation reading a class retelling
or rubber ducky so Gretchen I'm a big
fan of the word grunting um because we
are all ashamed of it but the thing is
this is the truth everybody does it it's
nothing to be ashamed of
so the thing is you generally won't use
crap very very rarely he will actually
use grad P of a prep probably use your
IDE to do all sorts of different kinds
of searching so or you sometimes you
will do an actual grant it happens but
it also things like follow symbol or
find usages or all sorts of these kinds
of searching things where you don't
really know where things are I put them
under grepping and generally what you
will grep for and I'll continue to call
it reppin generally what you will see is
that the first thing that you will look
at if you're trying to fix about is you
found an error in your logs from one of
your frameworks and you don't know what
it means so but there will be a string
there there will be a name of the
exercise
there will so be something that you can
grab for say so that's like a first
thing that is something that you can do
if you're trying to learn a GUI
application and you're trying to make me
I want to add a button over here to do a
thing then look at a button close to it
find a string that is on a button close
to it search grep for the string on the
button generally if it's a string you'll
end up in a localized localization
mapping file and then you find a
constant then you get for the constant
it's like most of you have done many of
these things but you haven't realized
that everybody else does too
but you can also have things if you have
a command line too then you can look at
the man pages find stuff there and grep
for those things there's many different
things that you can observe from the
outside of this program that can lead
you to one place that you understand
because that is the one thing here you
understand where it's coming from either
there's this button or there was an
error here which probably is related to
whatever you were trying to do any real
application which you understand and
we'll look at them where is this button
because that is often with a GUI
application a very good place to start
just pick a button or an interesting
button so like I said you get for the
button text you find the button okay
great now you found the button
definition what do you do now well you
tried to find the unclick generally in
almost any kind of GUI framework there
will be an onclick somewhere close to
the button definition so just try to
find the onclick if it might involve
more grepping and and then you set a
breakpoint on this now of course now we
it's we're assuming you have a debugger
right if you hadn't gotten to the point
of getting it running it in the debugger
then this will be difficult but let's
just say that you did so you click the
button and then when you break on your
breakpoint then you have two very
valuable things that you can learn you
will break where the focus is on the
widget that you just clicked and you
know where that is like visually you can
see where it is studying the
the state of that widget and also to
versing up the widget hierarchy will let
you know like okay so this parent is
this view plane okay so they have like
this view thing and this view is inside
of oh okay they have this kind of layout
thing and then you kind of just oh and
it's in this dialogue in this dialogue
it's the parent of has the main window
as a parent and now suddenly you
understand a little bit about the
structure of the UI so then you have a
more bottom-up approach and this is the
most most important like most
interesting if you're looking at more of
a GUI framework that you're trying to
understand so a GUI framework has
basically two functions okay
they have lots of features but they have
two functions they have to fulfill they
have to take platform events and give
them to somebody if that be clicks
button presses Keys whatever something
coming from the platform has to be given
to the right thing you might not so this
is this is like a very central piece any
kind of GUI framework has to do this and
the second thing they have to do they
have to produce a frame which paints
your entire application and it has to
give this frame to the platform so that
the platform can somehow display it
somewhere these two things all GUI
frameworks have to do and they are so
central that if you kind of figure out
where those things are you will find a
lot of the core code and a GUI framework
you will have tons of like feature stuff
all around but if you want to understand
the true function of the framework then
finding out where it gets the events and
how it distributes them and how it
produces the final frame you have the
core part of the framework so this is
again trying to narrow down from
hundreds of thousands of files to maybe
you know a couple of hundred made me
less write something that you can
actually work on
then you have what do the tests do my
last step in the in preparation was
tried to run the tests because it's
quite useful in different ways
and when I say test I don't really mean
unit tests I'm talking about integration
of system tests unit tests for
understanding somebody else's code are
generally useless and they are really
good at catching you when you are trying
to mess around in somebody else's code
that you don't know when you are
probably breaking something the unit
test will tell you but they are very bad
there are two fine-grain to really give
you any good information because what
you're trying to understand is a big
thing it's not a small thing so if you
have integration system test they will
exercise this application in some way
they will show you how do you set up
this application to be run what are the
use cases because generally these kinds
of tests will be reflecting of use cases
like make an account delete item from
cart they will have like these kinds of
names so you kind of understand what
does this thing do and one thing that
you can do if you have like a specific
thing that you're looking at you can
write your own test and that is a good
way of exercising exactly the flow that
you want to look at because now it's
like you can stop started you can do it
many times and you can also test your
assumptions so writing an integration
test is also a good way of trying to
figure out the part that you're looking
at and then we come to the most
dangerous part of the whole list because
it has to be on the list because you're
gonna do it the problem is refactoring
is really opinionated refactoring in its
essence says that what I am now doing is
better than what was there it's very
hard to come and say I refactored
something and now it's just as good or
worse than what was there before
so so that is that is the first thing
there's no way anybody's gonna buy that
argument so to go into this we are
trying to be friends with these people
right we're trying to make them like us
and also anyway if you're not going to
upstream this patch don't really factor
because you have to maintain it when you
get new versions and refactoring gives
you absolutely no functionality but lots
of work so my tip is to start off
knowing you're going to throw it away
this would there will be a reset hard
today or tomorrow this is going to go
away the only reason you're doing this
is because sometimes is easier to learn
if you just get your hands dirty and you
mess around and you break stuff and then
you realize
aha okay so this depends on this other
thing and this is the reason why this
seems really dumb because there was this
other thing that I didn't know about so
I'm not saying you shouldn't refactor
I'm just saying don't show it to anybody
okay so then we have reading Maine
and I have Maine in quotation marks
because Maine here is anything that
drives execution in the part of the code
you're currently looking at and so that
could be in a smaller application or if
you're looking at a big application you
want to understand the whole thing kind
of the underlying core parts of it then
you look in Maine what Maine is depends
on your language it depends on your
framework it depends on a lot of things
but it you will generally have some sort
of code that runs at startup that
handles all your bring up application
code and some part of your code that
will tear everything down so this is me
whatever that is
starts any kind of loops or things or
create objects that are going to last
for the entire lifetime of the
application so here the reason why is
important to look at is especially in
the venture of an application this is
where you're going to find your your
main loop and your event handling and
that is very important at any kind
interactive application because it will
show you how this works like how do
people do stuff around here you will see
that okay here everybody sets up their
event handlers and then and then when
they need something done they just issue
and an action or an event or whatever
they do depending on what are you doing
it's at some point this will be picked
up by somebody from a queue and suddenly
you understand a lot about the flow so
this is the one part I will say read it
from top to bottom because hopefully
we're talking about like limited amount
of code and it's very central cone and
this is also where I would recommend
taking lots of notes and drawing writing
down all of the important classes that
you see any kinds of things that are
passed around like you see like they
have like this control object they keep
on sending to everybody all the time
there's generally really important stuff
inside of that one so you might want to
go and check and then you might find
central and ownership you might find
central functionality that everybody
needs a lot of like cross-cutting
concerns might be in things that are
just being passed around so this setup
and teardown will tell you a lot about
the architecture and of course a lot of
people have generally tried to make this
like easier to read so they've pushed
everything out and like functions that
have nice names so you have to kind of
go digging a little bit generally but
this is the opportunity to have like the
high level view of the startup and
teardown okay so graphical layer when we
talk about the graphical layer we're
talking about some kind of application
actually has a GUI and what what that is
that could be anything right it could be
a native application it could be a web
application it could be anything but it
has some kind of graphical user
interface so here we're looking for the
engine inside of the graphical user
interface and I call that the main
layout the main layout the best way to
describe it really is if you take an
application like for example Gmail the
first time you go to Gmail you get a
login page
and then if you are you not user of
Gmail then you have a little link that
says like sign up you click on the sign
up then you go to the sign up page and
then when you sign up blob about maybe
it lets you login or maybe it sends you
back to login and you have to login
again
but great and then you come in and you
have the list of emails now if you
notice there are two things about the
way I talked about this first of all the
whole window changes like it's totally
different it's not like I just added
something here or it's been there
changes there it's like I started with
the login page and now I have a list of
emails you know you click on an email
and then you're in compose view it's
like totally different so you have two
things one that the GUI changes
dramatically and secondly it generally
corresponds to something that sounds
like a user story like I would like to
open my email what kind of thing it
generally has like open email login sign
out you will generally have like
recognizable words now for people who
have done GUI applications for a long
time they will generally pull this out
into an actual state machine so you will
have state transitions in the state
machine to handle this and transitioning
from one state to another means the
window changes so if you are in the
login state then and you managed to log
in then you will have a transition to
view email State now if you haven't done
Google applications a lot you don't
realize you need this in the beginning
and then you have lots of boolean so you
have like has logged in its viewing
email and you end up with like having
like a list of boolean's that says that
something is true or false and then you
have lots of ifs testing if this is true
and that is true and this is not true
and either way this is an actual state
machine even if it's not really clear so
if you find this code the code that
controls the transition from one state
to another this is going to be very
central code for the architecture of a
GUI application
okay so then we come to run time
investigation because we talked a little
bit about run time investigation but
this is it's often a thing that people
think is the only thing so and and quite
frankly it's just one tool but one thing
that is also very interesting is if you
talk to people that are generally like
back-end developers and you have people
who are generally front-end developers
and front-end here could be anything
that has like a user interface or is
highly interactive in some kind of way
or has has requirements that it can
never block which are front end kind of
concerns and then you have a back-end
developer generally gets a request and
will do processing and when they're done
with the processing they will give you a
response this is a very very easy thing
to do the reason why it's very easy is
because you have a very fixed set of
input and you get it all at once and you
cannot finish until you done everything
and then you finish and it takes as long
as it takes and people might get pissed
off and think it shouldn't take ten
minutes to write something to the
database okay that's a different problem
but it but the thing is that what you
will see is that a back-end type of
developer is used to working with with
code that is highly synchronous and if
you are used to working with code
there's hardly synchronous and that's
not only back and code that it's also if
you write like a command-line tool also
very highly synchronous you get some
input you have to produce some output
there you can do a little bit of async
stuff but you basically have to finish
before you can do your response so you
kind of have to wrap it up at the end of
every request the thing is if you are
used to that kind of coding you use of
debugger a lot because it's really easy
because we break some place and they can
step through the whole thing from start
to finish it's really nice you can go
like ah now I want to step over that
function and I want to and they're very
used to that way of thinking if you do
primarily front-end the
isn't that great because generally
everything is async so it's like yeah
I'm doing a very interesting thing and
poof okay
I'm not here anymore at certain point I
will have a call back I'm not exactly
sure who handles this call back it might
be myself I might have the function but
maybe it's going to be delegated to some
kind of event handler or someplace and I
don't know where that is so if you're
asynchronous the code you're dealing
with this asynchronous this is kind of
hard so here I would say do add lots of
logging everywhere and then run through
your use case figure out where you hit
and set breakpoints there and then you
were like okay I came to my asynchronous
thing okay then I just continue I hit my
other breakpoint and then I continue and
I hit my other breakpoint and there's
like but there was something happening
between here just add more logging until
you realize where you're going to have
to jump between the steps because
sometimes you have code that is really
complex and you could possibly hit many
different places depending on all sorts
of conditions that you don't know so and
this is often frowned upon right
it's called printf debugging it's
basically it's like I don't use the
debugger I just put in print statements
everywhere but I'm saying that these
things complement each other and
especially if you're working in a highly
asynchronous application and also I put
profiler in parenthesis but it might be
interesting especially if you're looking
at something like a memory profiler or
if you have anything that will produce
like call graphs for you that might be
interesting to look at so like I said
you had like I said an event-driven
application they would generally have
the main loop as sometimes it's hidden
for you from you like in JavaScript you
generally don't see the main loop there
is a main loop but you will recognize it
by having lots of async in it and event
handlers request handling generally back
end and the easy thing there is again
it's code-wise or like execution-wise
it's actually much more similar to a
command line tool because you get input
new produce output and you can't produce
the output until you're done for some
value of done
but the difference between the back end
thing is that you generally just spawn a
new thread to handle each request you
often have very few hopefully cross
cross dependencies between these if you
do that's generally an issue but that's
another talk okay yeah so you use the
lungs to really see the flow you use the
test to drive the flow like I said
before you can write a system test or an
integration test to exercise the exact
code path you're looking at if you
manage to do that it's very easy to do
it many times it's like if you have to
bring up the application and push
through like 50 buttons before you can
do your thing it's going to get annoying
very fast so if you have something where
you can just press play and it will just
hit all your stuff this is going to be
much easier and I would also say trying
to add a feature even if it's like it's
a dumb feature it was like I'm going to
add a button right next to my button
which I don't know prints something to
the log or I don't know sends an email
or I don't know something dumb that
you're actually are never going to
commit you have to understand a lot to
add a feature you have to understand how
everything is hooked up and for some
reason it's like you think you
understand something it's like when you
go to a talk at a conference and you're
listening and you're like yeah I get
this it's like yeah I'm gonna go home
and do this and then you come home and
they're like it sounded perfectly
reasonable but I heard are we sure I
understood this thing so doing something
is often very different than then
reading something so trying to add
something even if it's used this might
actually be very useful okay so we've
done a lot of stuff to try to narrow
down the code right because we started
with something that might be arbitrarily
large and now we're trying to narrow it
down to something that is manageable
something that that boils down to the
stage where you can actually print it
and read it in your chat which is nice
so but even here classes come in
different flavors some come in thousands
of lines tens of thousands of lines so I
would also do a top-down kind of
approach so the first thing I would look
at what kind of interfaces does this
thing in implement what is it what it's
the role that it plays for others
because that will make you understand
what other types of code that uses this
thing what do they use it for what kind
of function does it perform for other
pieces of code then you know use usages
and stuff like that in your ID and try
to figure out who actually uses it and
look at the code that uses it because
then you will see what are they like the
most important functions in this class
like if you have a very strict coding
style in this then you can just look at
the public functions but very often
people have like stuff that's public
that nobody else ever uses right so you
kind of have to narrow down what is the
actual used public interface of this
thing and these functions will be your
mains now like a tiny main right because
these are the functions that drive
execution these are the ones that
kickstart this class without these calls
this class will never do anything so and
then you go and you do the regular thing
of reading it through trying to
understand the flow what types are used
things like that and then you come to
the last one and this is one that I
think we all do when we don't understand
something now it's gotten like this name
called rubber ducking but I'd like to
call it retelling and the reasons for
that is that rubber ducks are not very
motivational to talk to but the actual
like idea and I'm most of you probably
familiar with the idea it's that you you
are stuck in something so you try to
explain it to a actual literal rubber
duck and while explaining it you kind of
have to serialize all of your stuff in
your head
in two words and you have to kind of
bring them out and generally like when
you're halfway through you go like never
mind it's like and they're like what
happened it's like now and I never mind
I know exactly what was wrong because
the process of doing this of telling
someone this it actually makes you
understand things so if you're stuck and
you don't understand then try to explain
it to somebody often they don't have to
know anything or understand anything of
what you're saying but I would say say
to somebody or write it to something
like make it real enough that you will
take it seriously enough that you will
make the effort and that's why I think
Duck is not very motivating but you can
have something like making make an
internal presentation write this
documentation that we talked about is a
good way of like feeling like you have a
work product that somebody will look at
so it feels more important and you might
put more effort because really what
we're trying to learn is this code but
at the same time we're trying to also
get over our own inhibitions and fears
and all sorts of things and oh my god
this is too difficult and I don't know
what to do so you kind of have to get
through that the the psychology of it to
write because it's going to feel
overwhelming so the last thing and those
were the ten techniques like I said
before I would go through them it's like
just like if you feel like you're stuck
with one just pick another one and then
do that one and then generally you will
go back and forth as you learn more then
you can use then you can enrich the your
mental model because what you're doing
is you're building this mental machine
right trying to you got code but you
need to understand how this machine
works
this is and this is a little it's it's
little bit related to what I said about
about making people like you because
Google had a project called project
Aristotle how many people have heard
about this project
yeah a couple yeah and they were trying
to figure out what was the predictor of
team excellence and they did a lot of
studies on a lot of teams inside of
Google and they and they kept on doing
this for a few years and what they found
that didn't make any sense because they
couldn't find any kind of correlation
between excellent teams and the
excellence of individual team members
you had teams that bring like pretty
average but they were doing great and
then he had teams we had lots of
brilliant people and they were doing
terribly and so what they found they
found a few factors that were predictive
but they didn't really understand it and
then they were reading literature and
they came over some work that talked
about something called psychological
safety psychological safety is you
feeling and I'm not actually will read
it there it's the the work came from
this Amy Edmondson in this paper she
wrote called psychological safety and
learning behavior and work the term
means now the term is meant to suggest
neither a careless sense of
permissiveness nor an unrelenting
positive effect but rather a sense of
confidence that the team will not
embarrass reject or punish someone for
speaking up this confidence stems from
mutual respect and Trust among team
members we are really bad at this as an
industry and we are building instruments
things like code reviews and that are
really bad at this because we focus so
much I'm pointing out what is wrong that
it will feel you will feel very
vulnerable and it will feel safer not to
say something or not to do something and
to stay safe but if we all stay safe
then we are not doing our best work
because we are not contributing
everything that we could contribute but
if you felt safe in your team if you
feel like your teammates will listen to
you and even if you say something dumb
they will not bull you for it
then you might bring it up and then
somebody will go like you know what okay
that is actually brilliant because I had
this other idea because this is how you
bring all of the excellence from all the
different team members together and make
something that is better than each alone
and she talks about this matrix where
you have psychological safety going up
and then you have what she calls
motivation or accountability the other
way we generally don't have a problem
with what she calls this is this is a
murder that goes across industries but
what you can say is like motivation
accountability is basically self driven
feeling of that what you do is important
that it's meaningful that it matters
these are things that programs generally
never struggle with we we it's like even
dumb things we think is important to get
right it's like I don't care if this is
done but it's going to be good so we are
generally very good there and the hah in
this one what you will find is that if
people are bullied at work then they
will stop caring about what they make
because there's no reason to care
because it doesn't matter anyway because
nothing you say matters so you just shut
up and you don't care and you just go
through the motions if you get up to
that then you're going to end up in
apathy apathy is not good it's not good
for the workplace but it's not good for
you personally this is where you burnout
right but you don't only burn out there
you burn out in the other one now you're
highly motivated but you are not
psychologically safe so you want to do a
good job but you can't because whenever
you try to do something you are just
torn down
this in the beginning you feel like I'm
going to fight through this
but after week after week after week of
people just punching you down you can't
and this is why you can end up with
people actually having PTSD from their
work so what we want is to move up in
the psychological safety and here is a
very interesting thing because if you're
a manager you're really afraid of people
ending up in comfort comfort this one
you don't really care but you it's nice
here people are nice the thing is is in
my experience programmers are generally
intrinsically highly motivated they are
generally never like lazy people who
just like sitting around and take coffee
but okay there are people like that we
have all met a couple but it's like
ridiculously high percentage like if you
compare to people washing dishes in the
cafeteria it's like we have like 98
percent of people who actually are
interested in what they do at work
whereas if you wash dishes in the
cafeteria not so much you do it for
money right and then there's nothing
wrong with doing for money take
that money but but so you generally
don't have to worry about that scale so
what we're trying to do is okay so you
want to increase psychological safety
and that's when you come into this
learning mode where you listen to people
you learn from them
you teach each other and you feel safe
enough to contribute everything you have
and this is something that everybody
kind of wants to do and everybody's
struggling here right this whole
industry we've been really bad at this
but this is especially hard for
minorities in tech because they are
holding back on so many things and
they're holding back on so many things
that we need we need to know that our UI
is not accessible we actually want our
co-worker that is colorblind but never
told anybody to tell us that there's no
way to tell the techs from the
background because
and you know and if everybody is hostas
good gel team and everybody trusted so I
think he's gonna go like this is
we can't have this this doesn't
work it's like I can't even read it and
you know and then you know like okay
it's like it's a common that people are
Brown it's like yeah it's like okay then
we have to fix that okay does anybody
know how to fix that and then you work
it out um if you have someone who's
non-binary openly non-binary at work or
transgender then they might say why are
you asking for gender in this you are we
don't really need it it's going to make
a lot of people uncomfortable if you
have somebody who is in the closet I
work they are never gonna say that and
that is information that you don't get
because you didn't think about it so
then you do stupid things and like we
saw in the keynote this morning and then
it's a good example of the kind of
centrist ism that we've had in tech a
ski really you have like seven bits and
you go like you know what the only
language in the world that matters is
mine it's it's it's and we do it again
and again we have we have like snapchat
you know that's like fancy filters with
like stuff in your head I don't use it
but you know people like that
the first releases of snapchat with the
little ears only showed up on white
people so I don't even know how you do
that because the thing is you know it's
like you know all of us know we always
play around with everything and we make
at work all of us like and then somebody
goes like ah come on if you were making
these ones in the ears everybody in your
workplace are putting on the ears and
you're playing around with a long time
before it's shipped right if you don't
realize that the wiggly ears don't show
up on black people before it's out that
says one out of two things either you
have only white people it's not unlikely
or all of the black people that show
then
did see that they didn't show up they
didn't say anything and they didn't say
anything because they were down here
they were at the bottom and they were
not feeling safe to speak up so going
towards this learning thing you might
think okay but maybe there's a trade up
because we're not like whipping people
for excellence but what I'm saying is
actually this whipping thing is ruining
our excellence it's making us worse and
that is exactly what Project Aristotle
found out that teams who where the
members feel safe with each other
perform better than teams where they
don't and so this is not a trade-off
this is a win win people feel better at
work and you do better work and that's
back to what I said about this is not a
code of video dealing with people's code
is personal great code should be
personal we keep on talking about that
you shouldn't take it personally this is
absolute crap you should take it
personally if you don't take your code
personally you are not trying your best
you should take it personally because
you actually did your best to do this
and you try to do it as well as you
could and if it is it shouldn't
make you feel bad I'm not saying that I
want you to feel bad but that is how we
always feel it's like being a programmer
it's like a roller coaster emotionally
it's like you're a rock star and then
you're like this most stupid person in
the world but it's like what we do we
can do that like five times a day and we
do it for the Rockstar moments movie
like the like oh my god what am I even
doing here I can't believe they pay me
money so what I'm saying is is it is
personal be nice to each other and
meaning somebody else's code means you
have an opportunity to learn learn from
them and they might be different from
you and it might not be that their style
fits your style it might be that the way
they do things is not exactly how you
would do things
doesn't mean they're wrong things can be
different and still be good and so back
to being safe if you want to enter a new
team then going in like I'm a rock star
you have to love me because I'm going to
rip all your stuff apart is not a good
way to make people like you and it's not
a good way to build a team so learn to
appreciate other people learn to
appreciate their code and try to build
trust in your teams because that is how
we will become truly excellent and all
of my photos I get from pixabay and of
course my my twitter handle has been on
everything right so just my DMS are open
so just do me and that's my presentation
now we have quite a bit of time like 10
minutes for questions and I won't be
upset if somebody needs to leave so just
sneak out if you want to but if somebody
has any questions please yes when I this
is it's hard I think first of all I
think we have spent too much time doing
style reviews way too much like I don't
like that you didn't have a space here
and I don't like that you do this thing
which is not so I think we are spending
only like in my experience like 10% of
the review on actual functional things
because looking at functional things
takes more time you have to like spin up
the machine you have to manipulate it
you have to figure out what this thing
does it's a lot of work it's much easier
to just scan the text and go I like my
curly brackets in a different way so I
think we should should back off a little
bit on the whole style thing because it
is not really productive but I also
think that we could try to be better at
at praising people like basically saying
that if you are going to comment in a
code early you have to say something
nice - you have to say like okay I
really like how you solve this thing
here that really makes it a lot more
elegant than it was before and so that
is great I love that and this other
thing over here I was wondering maybe we
could do it in a different way I was
thinking maybe this way what do you
think there's many ways of saying things
right yep
yeah and then and in that way you can
also find things as suggestions rather
than commands yes yeah and then you were
like oh okay I didn't know that and then
you also learn yeah yes
we're still pretty we're still pretty
new in this trying to figure these
things out so far we are in very like
starting phases where we are introducing
koto conducts but at the same time maybe
the the leadership in the community are
not actually invested right so they make
the code of conduct but they don't
actually mean it and so there is no
enforcement and and also you have
globally not only intact but also very
much in tech this this discussion
between people who think that I should
be able to say whatever I want no matter
who hi who I hurt right there's plenty
of those people and and so you have to
decide what you want your community to
be and you have to back it up and I've
been working for the last nine months
I'm building such a community with a
bunch of other people in C++ because
this is like in C++ it's like the
probably the least diverse programming
language it's like I would say in my
experience there's like wanted to
present women and know openly gay people
and it's and and and you have you have
generally as many trans women as you
have non trans women that's how many
women you have and you've had very much
this very raw very hard kind of attitude
and we created a discord which we call
hash include' and one of the reasons we
made it was we said that we are making
it based on a code of conduct and we are
going to be super strict and that is the
leadership saying that we will be super
strict
if you cross any line we will kick you
and in the beginning people don't know
they don't know how strict are you right
it's like people will come they will
push that will see how far can I step
close to the line how far can I go over
the line and we are like
but the reason why we're doing that is
that there are very few spaces that are
safe for my no it isn't a tack very
often very simple things can get you
stalked online can get you can get you
doxxed online can get in some some parts
of the Western world can bring Nazis to
your doorstep for I'm gonna minority in
tech you can be physically threatened
and so creating that space was very
important to us but I have to say as an
industry we need to change even if I'm
not saying I protect the minorities as
an industry we're making stuff like
what I said about the the the moogle
years and that wasn't really important
but you had like the first version of
the the Apple watch couldn't measure a
pulse on people with black skin we are
making medical devices that have only
been tested on white men mmm large
majority of medical research is done on
white men and that sucks not only for
women that sucks for everyone is a lot
of white men we we need to realize that
we need diversity in all of our
workplaces to make stuff that works for
everybody we're not making stuff only
for our local communities anymore we are
making stuff that is global and we need
to address the needs of everybody and
then we need those perspectives in our
teams but we also need them to feel safe
enough to say it when we're doing
something dumb any more questions
okay thank you
[Applause]